mobilisation parviennent également en
soutien au peuple palestinien
aujourd'hui et demain
cette photo risée elles devront
toutefois rester statique après décision
du préfet mobilisation qui intervient
après les affrontements sanglants de ces
derniers jours entre le hamas et l'armée
israélienne on y retrouve notre reporter
du cadet ses bons jours l'udc alors
comment se passe ce rassemblement
statique
et bien me reiss et plusieurs centaines
actuellement sur la place de la
république malgré des conditions météo
qui sont pas toujours très favorable il
a beaucoup plu tout à l'heure c'est
manifestants ont reçu la visite du
secrétaire général de la cgt philippe
adivèze qui a exprimé sa solidarité avec
le peuple palestinien tous ces
manifestants ici revendique que cette
cette solidarité avec le peuple
palestinien et considère qu israël jouit
d'une impunité dans séchage histoire que
cela soit la colonisation ou les
expulsions de palestiniens
quoi qu'il en soit je vous propose
d'écouter plusieurs manifestants que
j'ai pu interroger au début de cette
manifestation il ya un cessez-le-feu et
c'est très bien nous sommes preneurs
maintenant il faut que l'apartheid cesse
parce que l'apartheid en israël continue
l'occupation continue la colonisation
continue et nous voulons que tout ceci
c'est ce qui n'est pas de temps en temps
comme ça épisodiquement
et puis où est même régulièrement d une
répression féroce qui s'abat sur le
peuple palestinien que ça soit en
cisjordanie et à jérusalem à gaza ou
même ton chez les palestiniens d'israël
le peuple pas les siens iil est il est
en grand danger et il faut que le
retournement de la société civile ils
interviennent vite et fort notamment à
travers le développement de la campagne
de sanctions contre israël de boycott
désinvestissement sanctions la campagne
bds de manière à ce que israël sache que
l'occupation et la répression
ben c'est pas gratuit ça a un coût une
autre cible de ces manifestants c'est
l'état français qu'ils accusent de
complicité passive en ne condamnant pas
assez forts les agissements d'israël et
aussi il les accuse d'avoir entravé le
droit de manifester notamment en
interdisant la manifestation de la
semaine dernière qui s'était terminée
dans des heures il y avait eu 45
personnes placées en garde à vue
aujourd'hui à cette manifestation allait
statique
le défilé qui était prévu jusqu'à la
place de la madeleine a été interdite
merci lucas pour toutes ces précisions